[Music]
the correspond simply them has helped me
further Advance my career in the data
management center it helped me graph and
property at the data analytic means into
my organization of course with a very
decent salary hike hey my name is
I was hosted in 2018 to work for the
wear in Mali to work for the world's
largest peacekeeping organization my
first project with the united nation was
in 2016 when I joined the unhcr the
United Nation High Commissioner for
refugees as the operating data manager
my contract with the world's largest
Distributing organization was coming to
an end and I was looking for more
responsibilities and law opportunities
so I decided to advance my career with
the latest technologist
is like in the field of data and having
the background in data management I
decided to start with the data analytics
master program from Simply neck achieves
simply land because of the Simplicity of
it courses I took the data analytics
master program last year and now I'm
actually doing the artificial
intelligence course from the simply land
after completing my course with the data
analytics Masters program I got an
opportunity into mining organization
with a very decent salary after the
certification from Silverman from like
for the data analytics Masters program
course because of that my salary was
renewed with five percent hike the job
comes in with more responsibilities as
compared to the earlier my work is much
more transversal it comes with high
responsibility I was working for a
single section in single unit where I
collect the data and analyze it now I'm
in the field technology the project and
data analytics support whereby we
interact with all the sections across
the mission in terms of data analytics
so I think at some point in time we need
to set up a goal and those goals we work
on it in order to achieve it